we're going to start out with our
science critic he made a 45 minute video
criticizing
the scientific method
can you believe that the scientific
method decided scientific of course
but yeah anybody's entitled to criticize
it right the question is whether uh his
criticisms have any validity so let me
uh set this up so that you can hear in
his own words what he said okay
and give me a second here and when we're
ready um almost on our way here we go
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal are
is the universe irrational
is it possible to observe a wave
function
and does quantum mechanics propose the
collision of wave functions
those are all things that have been
observed though so are you saying that
the universe is irrational although to
be fair one of the things that i haven't
heard is colliding wave functions i have
heard of collapsing wave functions and
interfering wave functions but never of
colliding wave functions
okay
so uh two issues specifically one is
whether the universe is irrational and
the other one essentially you know uh
whether a wave function first can be
observed and then whether they can
collide
and so let's go over the first one
here's a rundown okay
and it goes like this uh it's not that
the universe is irrational it's that the
explanations people have for how the
universe works that are irrational and
there i'm giving you some examples uh
the warpage of space time or the
geometry of space-time is gravity
you know that's an irrational statement
you're saying that um
time
has geometry
it's like saying that what's the
geometry of love what's the geometry of
intelligence what's the geometry of
consciousness the shape of time is that
what they're asking for well they're
essentially that's what it is because
they're the physical interpretation that
they're going to give is this bending of
the canvas the canvas represents space
and time and so essentially they're
saying that they're warping time and
that's gravity and
it's okay if you want to do math and say
look time
goes slower or faster that's that's one
issue but when you give a physical
interpretation you cannot say that time
is warped which is essentially what they
have and then the others uh zero d black
hole you know uh a lot of people are not
aware that uh chandrasekhar got a nobel
prize for proving that a black hole
is zero dimensional it collapses to zero
size and people don't like to hear that
they say what do you mean zero size yeah
that's exactly what chandrasekhar got
his nobel prize for okay and so you have
an object that is zero size no volume
lots of mass
which is a concept in this no volume no
no size uh region and it makes stars go
around and pulls matter in yeah sure
and then uh the other particles have two
places at once big bang creationism and
uh you know just an example there faster
than light tachyons arriving from the
future you know what is all this and so
um
it's not that the universe is irrational
it's that these people are giving
irrational explanations for how the
universe works the irrational uh the
irrationality consists primarily in the
movement of concepts okay that's that's
essentially the
the the where the problem is we're just
using magic at all i mean not even
messing black match yeah i mean even
even magic can't make one thing be in
two places at once like no one
understands it you can't even make a
program that makes sense of that like no
no i guess not right because uh if you
give it up if you assign a name to one
object in your program
i guess as soon as you have two
locations two objects like that's
basically the definition of two two
things is because it has two locations
yeah so this is these are the things
that you gotta keep in mind that they
have irrational explanation the universe
i'm sure works rationally i hope it does
to a certain point i mean but it gets
weird at the
at the infinitesimal level when you're
at the at the fundamental level it gets
a little weird but i guess at some point
it kind of has to yeah but not that
weird the way i look at it is mother
nature father universe god devil the
devil whoever you pray to you know
they don't know anything about concepts
okay we invented all concepts so they
work with objects you know all they do
is move objects from one place to
another every day primarily atoms you
know they work at the atomic level so
there's constant motion in the universe
of what of atoms that's it that's all
they understand all these concepts field
energy mass we've invented all that they
you know mother nature and father
universe they know nothing about all
that they never would like i like to say
uh mother nature never went to school
she knows nothing about math or
arithmetic okay that's us that give you
know these relations
anyways um the second issue was uh
whether you can have
uh a wave whether you can observe first
of all a wave function and then whether
wave functions can
collide can they actually collide i put
that in there and this was what was he
was what this fellow was criticizing but
he conceded at least that they uh
interfere and that they um collapse
and what he didn't understand is that
there's no difference between uh
interfere
uh collide and collapse because you're
treating the wave function as a physical
object in all three cases that's the
issue okay so let's look at can you
first issue is you know can you can you
even observe a wave function and a wave
function is what the second word says
it's a function and what's a function
it's an equation it's a number it's an
amount it's a quantity uh
so you can't say that a function uh that
you can observe a function like floating
out there in space that's the issue and
if you can't observe it first of all
then how can you imagine that it
collapses okay or interferes with
another wave function i mean what are we
talking about is this physics is this we
have two wave functions that hit each
other that cross each other what is this
and so you know here the uh first issue
is how do you observe uh numbers you
know floating around moving right you
can't do that um
how do numbers collapse what do you mean
by a number collapsing and what they uh
what they're saying in in quantum
mechanics is the following so let's
understand this well so that we truly
understand it okay
uh they say that the uh wave function
collapses to a point
why because when they take the
measurement
they take a measurement at a given spot
at a given point and they say what
happened was that this wave function
which is spread out throughout the
universe all the way to the edge of
space-time suddenly collapses
you know
concentrates all of a sudden
uh to a dot
and that dot is what they're going to
call a particle
so let's look at what a particle is this
is from the
wikipedia an idealization of particles
heavily used in uh i think they said
mathematics but maybe i was too liberal
with my wording there okay but it's
defining feature is that what it lacks
spatial extension being dimensionless it
does not take up space
we're talking about nothing yeah why
because we're talking about a concept
they're talking about a number a
quantity that's what a particle is says
a particle is an appropriate
representation of any object whenever
its size shape and structure physics you
know are irrelevant in a given context
so they're talking about first a wave
function what is a wave function a bunch
of vectors what is a vector it's got
magnitude and direction and you have a
bunch of these arrows which represent
magnitude and direction and they're
moving sideways perpendicular to those
directions right they're moving sideways
and suddenly all these vectors numbers
right they collapse
to what they call a particle which is
what no spatial uh
volume no dimension dimensions they take
up no space basically they just i bought
a location with
this stores properties exactly that they
measured
and so uh how do numbers physically
interfere because forget about my
colliding i put the colliding in there
forget about that if you want no problem
that's that's my
take but how do they interfere and how
do they collapse what are we talking
about are we saying that this equation
collapses to a dot that or a point a
ball some kind what's that collapse yeah
so colliding interfere and collapse in
all three cases whichever one you you
want to pick there is a physical
interpretation of what they measure
and this is where the problem comes in
are we doing math are we doing physics
if you want to do math no problem
measure all you want give me the
quantity no problem but when you say
that the number collapses to a little
ball
now we have a little bit of problem
that's where the problem is okay that we
have a number collapsing to a ball okay
and that's scary well sometimes like
what you said earlier about the warp
space could you say something like
you can calculate useful things for with
mathematics as if it were warp space so
use the calculations for a warped canvas
but once you translate that into real
life as a physical mechanism it gets
weird where we would be crushing the
bottom of the earth on the surface of
space time
so as an equation
it's useful but as a physical
interpretation it makes absolutely no
sense right and that's where the problem
is the problem is that uh the physical
interpretations and when people don't
understand that they say okay these
people know all that math they probably
know what they're talking about i don't
understand that that well you know no
the question is they don't have a
physical interpretation that you can
take to the bank that's what bothers the
point really because a lot of them
reject that as philosophy and they say
well that's for us that's opinion that's
what they what the particle looks like
who cares right it's like we don't care
about that we don't give a uh you know a
real physical interpretation we don't
understand how that works we don't care
about that because we're doing math and
we call that physics now no physics is
what mother nature does you need to
explain gravity you need to explain
magnetism electricity how the atom works
that's physics but if you just measure
and give me an amount and say this is
how fast something is this is how much
it weighs or how much mass it has now
you're talking about numbers yeah it's
just describing yeah and so you cannot
translate that
or
automatically convert it into physics
and say it's a ball that's you know ways
space-time downwards or whatever that's
where the problem is the the transition
from math to physics again uh
mathematical physics is a contradiction
in terms it's an oxymoron okay because
math is math physics is physics never to
twain shall meet
okay so here's a wave function just so
you see what it looks like okay what
they're talking about when they say a
wave function collapsed or it interfaced
or it uh interfered or collided or
whatever with another wave function here
it is that's what it looks like that
worm that you see there okay this is uh
follow who says
that
all these particles you know they form
this wave function and what are those
particles were their values so each one
of those balls that you see there that
form that uh worm
well all those balls are also quantities
they're just talking about quantities
quantities and more quantities and
that's what the two axis there are
really
indicating you know this is just a two
axis and numbers on a cartesian
coordinate system that's all we're
looking at okay so let's look at uh
let's look at what uh really a wave
function collapses okay here it is okay
it's scary stuff so if you're
this is not authorized for people under
18 so if you're under 18 please leave
right now okay this is dangerous stuff
here it is okay here you have the uh
wave moving before measurement and then
it collapses
to a dot
that's a wave function collapse you
never saw it well now you've seen it in
this channel okay and so the question is
here you have a bunch of vectors they're
moving uh
transversely with respect to the
direction of each one of those vectors
that represent magnitude and direction
so they have numbers that are moving
that's what you're staring at they're
represented by these arrows and suddenly
that whole bunch of numbers
collapses to a ball
which knows it's being watched
i never understood how physicists could
just accept that as an axiom like the
electrons know they're being watched
that matter reacts differently if their
eyes on it like that they just accepted
that like oh yeah that happens yeah in
one world the physical interpretation is
what is scary because in what was i
think 1926 when this was determined by
werner heisenberg and some of his pals
schrodinger and so on what they did they
uh they figured out things that they
could not see so they had the quantities
they had the measurements
but they could not see what they were
measuring in other words the the
reaction was uh invisible or too swift
so what they did was put particles in
there but initially they started with
classical particles because uh that's
what they thought they were and
classical particles are balls this is a
classical particle here that's what it
looks like okay uh it's a ball
and then they said well it's not really
a ball because it's actually another
quantity
that is at this location and so yeah
when you have that situation or you're
dealing with quantities but then the
physical interpretation gets lost in
translation that's what happens and
you're saying that a number converts
into a particle because they have to
give you a physical interpretation
because that's what the reporter is
asking for he says i don't care about
your numbers i mean what is it what's
the bottom line what does this all mean
and the guy says well you know the wave
function collapsed and so oh what is
that well the number turned into another
number but it's it's it's a pointed
number it's like uh in that region okay
in fact someone someone said it great
for for light
he said light travels
as a wave but departs and arrives as a
particle
that's the that's the definition or i
guess the the way of
representing light and what are they
saying what they're just saying in
nonsense they're saying that the parts
as a particle arrives as a particle in
between it's a wave so you you're not
you don't really have balls traveling
through the air that's not the notion
that they have they they represent it
that way but you saw just a minute ago
how the worm was made of all those
little balls so they still represented
that way because how are they going to
represent a wave if not with little tiny
balls that represent you know that whole
wavy thingy right but then they say it's
it departs as a ball it arrives as a
ball because that's what you can measure
at a point at a location in between it
travels or extends as a wave i mean
you know like take for instance
a wave of light a photon if you want to
see it that way a wave packet however
you want to see that
does it travel or does it extend
from the andromeda galaxy 2.2 million
light years away cramming at the speed
of light you would that's what the
distance is from there to the milky way
so does it extend from there to here or
does it travel and if it
if it travels where does the wave begin
where does the wave end i mean is it a
little robot that's uh you know
traveling through space without hitting
anything is that how it is or is it or
does it extend and if it extends what is
extending is a bunch of vectors